guys holy crap it's 2016 already this is
nuts
time flies just a year ago I was excited
to see Star Wars now we've seen it in
it's 2016
that is insane guys I'm doing a special
video here something I don't normally do
on my channel and I think it's
well-deserved because you guys are
awesome
don't worry I'm not going anywhere not
closing my channel down I'm not moving
away I'm not stopping everything's gonna
stay the same the reason I want to make
this video is because I recently
surpassed 500,000 subscribers on YouTube
that's crazy to me I can't even really
comprehend that and the honest truth is
I just want to give you guys a humongous
thank you it really means a lot to me
that you guys watch my videos and I mean
that sincerely when I discovered that I
love movies I wasn't sure how I was ever
going to share that with somebody I
didn't know how I was going to interact
with other people if I was gonna be able
to be a director or writer one day
professionally and I had no idea where
that love would go and even if I never
get to direct films in Hollywood or a
screenplay of mine never gets made I
will be perfectly happy with the fact
that I get to talk movies with you guys
every week and it's honestly a dream
come true and I owe all of that to you
guys so this is the only reason I'm
making this video I want to thank you I
really just want to let you know each
and every one of you that I really do
appreciate you and I appreciate the fact
that you guys enjoy these videos I do
read my emails I try to get on Twitter
and read those things I try to get on
Facebook and read those things I'm not
always good with that but I do read a
lot of what I get sent and I'm
constantly inspired by the things that
I'm told I am floored always by some of
the amazing response that I've gotten
from you guys and - thank you I'd like
to make two videos that you have been
requesting for quite some time
these are two videos I don't really want
to make because they take so much time
and they're actually very hard and
time-consuming to make but you guys
would like it and I owe you guys that
and so I'm gonna do that so my new
year's resolution is that within the
next two to three months I promise that
I will make a complete blu-ray
collection video Mobley this is going to
take some time you guys
don't realize this there's a shelf here
there's a shelf there there's another
ceiling-to-floor shelf of blu-rays right
there and in my basement it's gonna take
a long time there's no way I can talk in
depth about each one it's gonna be like
me holding them up and showing you like
it's like American Psycho here's my
story on American Psycho seventeen hours
later I'm done it's not gonna happen
I'll have to just kind of show you each
one I have rapidly but I will do it for
you guys and the other one is another
Q&A you guys have asked and really
wanted me to do a Q&A for quite some
time and so I will do one now you're
probably wondering where can I send
these questions I will set up an email
soon and in a future video I will give
you guys that email and you can send
questions to that email and I'll do
another Q&A I've done a few in the past
but I'll do another one I will very soon
probably on my next movie review for the
forest which comes out this weekend I
will give you guys an email to send
those questions to and that'll be a way
that I can thank you guys because half a
million subscribers to me is not
something that I really thought could
happen I started with zero and when I
was getting like 10 to 15 views per
video I thought wow some people are
actually watching my videos that's cool
even though five of them were from me so
all these years later what I keep trying
to do is just be myself and that's what
I do in my videos I've never allowed the
fact that you guys are enjoying this
content to change who I am I still I'm
just a dude in Ohio who loves movies and
I hope that in some way I can have a
positive impact on the film criticism
world the movie world hopefully in some
way I can continue to have a positive
impact on you guys as well thank you so
much as always for watching have a great
2016 you guys are the best if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck minimized
[Applause]
[Music]